Film Courage: You say Andy Dufresne is
not the protagonist in the Shawshank
Redemption? Brooks Elms, Screenwriter/Filmmaker:
That's correct. Technically the helpful way to
think about the protagonist is the one who changes
the most and has the most agency and impact on the
change. In that story Andy [Tim Robbins] for sure
drives the narrative, I mean he is a freight train
of hope all the way through that movie. He hopes
right in the beginning, he hopes in the middle and
he hopes at the end and he has a little bit of a
doubt here and there but for the most part he's
non-stop hope. He dug himself out of that damn
prison with like a spoon or something you know?
Ridiculous or I guess a rock hammer. Red [Ellis
Boyd 'Red' Redding] the Morgan Freeman character
is…it's not just that he's narrating but it's also
significant that he's narrating because he starts
in despair and he says and they get to the middle
and he's kind of picking up that this guy Andy
(and they've already been there 15 years at
that point) picking up he's this guy Andy's
all about hope and he goes “Hope? You can't hope
in here, it'll get you killed in here.” Right?
That's that part of us that considers hope
versus despair and that movie represents
red in that movie is the protagonist and he
represents how part of us can realize that when we
choose hope in no matter what situation especially
when it's really bleak like it is in that film
we actually liberate ourselves and we free
ourselves to the point where there's a character
named brooks and I really like that name brooks
where he gets out and the old guy is so you know
accustomed to that other people and is so he kind
of is sort of a happy-go-lucky character but like
he doesn't have enough hope and optimism
to be able to sort of rebuild his life
and so he turns right back to despair and
ends up killing himself really beautiful
turn and counterpoint to this idea of hope versus
despair but no for sure I would analyze that movie
with morgan freeman's character red being the
protagonists and one more thing about that
story is that when they I believe the way the
book ends which is really wonderful it ends with
Morgan Freeman or not Morgan Freeman the
Red character in the book just saying I
hope I hope he's basically learned to hope
and you don't know if he ever sees Andy
and to me that is sort of a deeper
more resonant lesson that like
it's easy to hope if you know you're going get
it the rub is can you hope can you believe can
you be open when you haven't gotten it yet and
you don't know if you're ever going to get it
and when red learns to do that even though
he hasn't gotten a reconnection with Andy to
me that really hits hard so I believe they did
that in the actual movie version and people were
pissed off they didn't like it so they think they
did they re-shot the ending where they actually
reunite and people loved it so you know we're in
service to the audience and I think the audience
loved seeing hope be overtly rewarded to them
it landed more deeply so when Stephen King
wrote the book it was a novella okay it's part
of a wonderful novella called different seasons
stand by me that movie was it was a movie it was
a great story called the body that's kind of like
the the Rob Reiner film but a little darker and
more interesting and so that and then apt pupil is
another one there's like four stories and I think
three out of the four were made into movies wow
and I understand that you said something about
and you did a video on your youtube channel about
how the law of attraction powers the Shawshank
Redemption and we can put a link to it below
here our video but you feel that the maybe the
title of the movie hurt its success in the initial
release yeah yeah for sure in my opinion and one
of my writing partners is one of the top marketing
minds in Hollywood so it doesn't mean that I'm
always wrong or he's a little bit like he's
he's good so I have a pretty good feel for
marketing stuff and my opinion is that when
you have an unusual title like what the hell
does that even mean Shawshank Redemption
everybody knows what Redemption means but
nobody knows what “Shawshank” means so
the job of marketing is you're beginning to tell
the story you never want to confuse people you can
intrigue them and I think that's why they justify
a title like that is that it's intriguing in a way
and in this case it was built on ip that maybe
people were familiar with and so they were kind of
you know letting it go but like the marketing
campaign and the title you choose is the beginning
of telling the story and the better way to tell
the story is clear this is what my story is
it's a story about this or that you know so that's
ideal but you know sometimes you know the coen
brothers always have kind of funky sounding
titles but like you know the cone brothers
movies get sold because of mostly them and their
brand and their sort of style their super power so
you know there's certainly exceptions to the rule
but I think if you take Shawshank Redemption and
you give it a different title it makes a much
bigger splash earlier on I mean it made a big
splash later because of the reaction but I
think there were much better titles than that
and I think the book was the book
like Ava Gardner or something read it
okay we're sorry the other other actress okay yeah
and then the Shawshank or something Rita Hayworth
and the Shawshank Redemption which is fine for
a novella you know I guess I don't know anything
about book marketing maybe no difference at all
there but in movie marketing there's so much noise
you absolutely will get a bigger audience when you
have a great title and it cuts right through the
noise in a way that totally beautifully positions
the audience for the rest of the story and it's
the beginning of the story that you tell so like
a knife you want a cutting through the noise
when you broke down the Shawshank
Redemption in your video
you talked about letting go of
outcomes and not being attached
if we think of a writer how should they let go
of outcomes or maybe they shouldn't maybe that's
something that's not that they shouldn't never be
too free-flowing with letting something go well
um they should always let go should
they be completely free-flowing
pretty much but not so like loosey-goosey where
you just kind of wander around aimlessly right
there's what we want for sort of to cross our
next career milestone as quickly as possible
we want to have a clear sense of where
we're going and conviction towards it and
a joy and an ease and a lack of attachment
and we don't ultimately it's about that
process of getting there the it's like the
way I talk about sometimes is that it's a
it's a treadmill you know you're you're jogging on
the treadmill and it's a beautiful treadmill and
once you get to one milestone guess what there's
just another milestone and then once you get to
that second milestone guess what there's another
milestone right so you're already on the damn
treadmill so this idea of I'm going to break
in well you write a screenplay today you've
already broken in essentially are you getting
paid for it yet no but the paradox is the less
attached to it and the more you're there just
to serve your audience as powerfully as you can
the quicker you'll cross the milestones that get
you to the point where they're paying you lots
of money you also broke down in your video victim
energy when it comes to the law of attraction and
attracting sort of victim circumstances
versus empowerment energy that's right how
do screenwriters do that oh wow you ever heard of
this thing called twitter actually you see both on
twitter really wonderful positive powerful energy
and lots and lots of victim choices I can't make
it to hollywood because of this excuse I'm to this
I'm to that I'm to the other they don't get me
woe is me I have no power it's just it's really
a fascinating choice that a habit that people
have of giving away the power giving away
the power giving away the power when we have
the choice to do the opposite take the power take
it off you know I'm responsible I can choose yes
hollywood has bias yes some groups are more
favored than other groups yes yes yes it's all
true and you can succeed despite that how you go
apples to apples you're trying to do this you're
seeing what's already out there with this you
figure out a way to close that gap you position
yourself as the best person to do the next you
know thing in this genre the person who's gonna
write horror in a new way or this in a new way
or that in a new way and if you do that they
don't care what you look like where you came from
at all you need to deliver the goods and in fact
if you are related to a celebrity or studio head
or whatever and that door is wide open for you if
you don't have the goods you're not going to get
work either this idea that nepotism is what fuels
all these things it's bs I mean it's a factor
but it's this much of a factor what's really
a factor is delivering the goods and if
you got the goods they don't care where
you came from they don't care who you are any
type if you've got the goods they'll be happy
to work with you and will try to sell you and
if you have all the connections in the world
and you're not delivering the goods guess where
you go director jail writer jail you get nothing
and that's exactly what happens there and these
ideas of that Hollywood's is closed place is bs
because of director jail you know what I mean it's
like you got to put up what's true is that you're
only as good as your last picture that sort of
thing I mean that's that's a negative way to
spin it but that's the truth I mean it's like
the internet makes pretty much anybody you want
to get to accessible you know one way than another
you're not everybody but like most of the people
or if not not them directly probably people they
know and if you impress them but the truth of it
is you know people just aren't developed enough
in their craft to do something that's impressive
enough to get to people who can get to people to
get it moving you know and then and instead of
just going okay yeah I'm on the way I'm learning
whatever they go oh Hollywood's closed people
you know they don't like my type because of this
or that and again there is bias I'm not saying
there isn't but it's a tiny part and when you
focus on the bias you are giving your power away
you are leaking it and you are distracting
yourself from your greatness and you are
you're just out of alignment from your
deeper goal which is to be in service of
your audience which is all about coming from
your power and being there and helping them
and in the Shawshank Redemption some of the
character arcs went from victim attraction
attracting victim-like situations to reversals
of that with let's say the prison warden
so he was maybe more empowered at one point
and then because of some things that he did
then it took a reverse turn whereas with
red it was so different character arcs
happen I mean how much should we be thinking about
things like that the law of attraction in relation
to our characters what are they attracting well we
shouldn't think about the law of attraction at all
unless we like it unless it speaks to us
unless we see real value in it there's
aspects of the way people talk about
the law of attraction that are really
sort of off-putting to a lot of people
and for good reason and and if you're
you know and if your curiosity stops there
then you shouldn't be thinking about it
it's been significantly beneficial for me and for
other people I’ve seen put it into practice things
happen and it feels good and it's fun and it's
easier and it works that's my experience people
should have their own experience and see if it
works for them maybe it does maybe it doesn't
for chocolate Redemption in terms of the victim
energy the first thing came to my mind was that
character that cracked that first night so so Andy
Dufresne comes in and then that heavier character
was he cracks he was he's the one that just
he gets so overwhelmed with his fear that
he ends up crying and I think that the guard
actually comes in and then beats him down and
he dies because of his wounds so and that from
a looked at from a law of attraction perspective
was like he brought that on himself he was so
deeply in the habit of giving away his power
not being able to feel the terror that he felt
being in this new place that he spiraled to a
place where he made things worse and he made
things worse and he made things worse to the
point where he actually killed him right and we
all do that sometimes and we all have the power
to do that a little bit less and a little bit less
and when we do it a little bit less so often that
we actually almost never do it we just hold our
power and we come from our power more often your
example about the warden is really interesting
so he starts out clearly with lots of power
and then comes to a point where but he's he's
completely corrupt so he's doing it he's not using
his power in service of his people so why what's
going on beneath that he's ultimately he's got the
material power he's in charge but he's not he's
not in alignment he's actually he's a victim and
he's he's a victim even though he's technically
in charge and he's coming from that victim place
as a tyrannical leader because the tyrannical
leader is not in service of his or her people
they are coming from their victim energy so
so when he falls at the end it is still saying the
same theme that it's always better to find hope
and despair and victim energy will always
cycle you down to terrible places even if you
are and that's actually that's the connection
between the two characters is that you have
the warden who started out very powerful
but basically was in this energy of victim
and lack and I didn't believe in genuinely serving
people so he had to cheat and steal and lie
and it basically drove him into a place of
despair and that character that came in as the
the fresh fish the the guy that cracked under
the pressure was the same thing but he didn't
he he just his demise happened so quickly because
he came he started from a place of less power
but they both are thematically proving the the
thematic statement of that piece that that when we
hope we get good things when we despair we get bad
things or from law of attraction language when we
are open to our power or we start with the
negative part when we are sort of bringing in
victim energy or lack energy or that sort of
thing it leads to despair when we bring in our
power and our flow and our ease and our belief
and our hope and our patience it leads to triumph
should so just the way people sort of use the
hero's journey yeah to as a backdrop against their
story if someone is open to the law of attraction
and whatever woo parts scare maybe some people
others are open to what what templates can they
apply to their story with the law of attraction
geez I don't know if I would call it a template
it's like my understanding the law of attraction
there's been you know people talking about this
probably for thousands of years in one way or
another but in the 20th century there was some
you know people writing about it sort of turn of
century and then in the last I know 20 30 years
there's been other people writing books about
it there was that movie the secret that that
was you know touching on it and but it's like
I don't know I mean it's yeah it's more of a it's
the tool that screenwriters can take from it is
more of a mindset approach it's like look the
doors are going to close in your career for sure
how do you want to respond to that in a way where
you're like oh no the door closed blah blah blah
that's terrible oh I didn't get into this you
know screenplay competition or oh this person
didn't buy my script or whatever it is there's
oh this person's not returning my phone call
you have a choice in how you can respond to that
and and when you choose to respond to that from
your inner sovereign energy as a king or a queen
saying I reached out to another kingdom and it
didn't work out fine reach out to another kingdom
and then reach out to another kingdom and then
reach out because you know why that's who I am.
I am a king and I reach out to other kingdoms
and I do business when I find my kindred spirits
and that's just it because this is a treadmill
and I'm just in it to be here and to do things
and yes at some point find the right person and we
can marry our kingdoms together and do something
amazing and until that point who cares because
I'm showing up as me and I'm just doing it.
Question
For The Viewers:
Who is the protagonist in
The Shawshank Redemption?